so when I initiate
if my hand
just rests on top and I take him down
it's nothing
because I haven't molded anything
if his hand is up it's kind of gosh
if his hand is down it's nicchio
or it could be Roku it could be the
sixth principle where I go for
the elbow
a knife taking
okay so we're going to work just slowly
on a few times I initiate
my cat's down and I turn me and I then
look at his hand and I say this is
nothing
I can't I could do coat of gosh if I
turn it and I throw the gosh has to be
like this because he should have struck
me
so if he does the strike down the
showman actually strike down
strike down
so there's his hand so then I didn't
alter his path
so then when I take it
is the current guy
okay so that's kind of guys I can do cut
the guys if I say my
if I try and turn it I've got nothing
I could turn it and say oh I do this one
but then it's me attacking him because
I'm trying to make something what wasn't
there if I initiate
then I have to guide his hand to this
position
if I'm too strong
I've guide his hand down incorrectly so
it's me putting too much of my own
intentions into the movement and I've
made nothing
can't do anything so
Saito since he says zero plus zero put
them together what have you got
zero so you've got to
understand that is the hand blade that
you need
then I initiate
so now I have to keep it like that
it wants to turn over I don't want it to
turn over
when I want it to turn over
I'll cut it round like this
and then it's the other way up
and then I've got Nick here
we need to spend a little time on this
today
great
thumb is up
I can do Kota gosh
some is down
I can do nicchio
so there's two techniques I've given you
some of you may have not seen this
before or understood it I initiate
at this point his hand wants to always
go that way I've got to try and do gosh
so I've got to roll my hand
slightly backwards to make the thumb
come up
I've got to
turn it as it's coming down to make the
coat guys
just this piece no Cami
hey Sama is cut a gosh
I'm down
just Nick here
the thumb plays a big part
cut down the thumb
plays a big start part and now both of
our thumbs are together
I take it in in here
essentially Bruce Quick's theme from
America he used to say I want to take
all of you and I want to push you
through to my you ignore them when they
tap because you're talking you you take
all of this and you push it through your
chest
out your shoulder blade at your back so
my feeling is look
there
okay all right so we'll do it with a
good one now ah
the sound
you bend it you don't just
you don't just bend it and put it on
here and lean in because if he leans in
as well you end up with a head back
I take it through my chest
through into my shoulder blade
and then when he's down then I can apply
it
give them a shake of the rest because uh
believe it or not it's a small thing but
it helps
ah
one down and go
uh
this is the whole thing ah
you cut them back into your Center like
that you go down
finish it
you can troll
and you get out of the way
let's try it now with a little bit more
inspiration and we'll just do the Nico